lucas les musées comme on le voit les
manifestants ont répondu présent oui
tout à fait amira il ya beaucoup de
monde qui est venu aujourd'hui le
cortège s'est un petit peu distendu
derrière moi il y a le cortège avec la
sono celui dans lequel se trouve florian
philippot florian philippot qui a été
acclamé lorsqu'il est arrivé ici le
leader souverainiste a appelé à cette
manifestation
notamment il avait organisé beaucoup de
manifestations déjà contre les mesures
sanitaires précédemment bien sûr
aujourd'hui le défilé est présenté comme
historique par les organisateurs puisque
ils s'opposent aux décisions des manuels
macro de détendre le pass sanitaires il
avait annoncé sa le 12 juillet une
mesure qui est jugée inadmissible par
ces manifestants je vous propose
d'écouter florian philippon que j'ai
réussi à voir ou début de cette
manifestation la foule parle d'elle-même
c'est historique
voilà il ya un monde fou et d'ailleurs
j'ai vu qu'en france y avait plein de
manif avec plein de monde aussi
en plus on est unis on est rassembler
des forces qui sont quand même de tuvalu
de tous horizons et ça c'est formidable
aussi et je crois que les gens disent
stop
voilà liberté toi pas sa discrimination
stop à cet apartheid
stop à cette tyrannie macro nist il faut
arrêter le délire kobe steel
autre critique de ces manifestants c'est
l'extension du passani terre à d'autres
aspects de la vie notamment autre que la
vaccination qui pourrait aboutir à une
vraie situation de crédit social comme
on peut le voir notamment république
populaire de chine je vous propose
d'écouter ce que disait nicolas dupont
aignan au début de cette manifestation
c'est le début d'un engrenage vers une
dictature c'est un coup d'état
sanitaires c'est l'instrumentalisation
de la peur de la maladie
pour asseoir un pouvoir de plus en plus
illégitime
voilà et je pèse mes mots et je les
assume à 100 % or le camp souverainiste
d'autres personnalités politiques se
sont opposés à la spa sanitaires pour
différentes raisons notamment pour
l'atmosphère de contrôle permanent
qu'elle induit notamment l'ancienne tête
de liste aux européennes
heller françois que saviez bellamy qui a
écrit une tribune dans le figaro pour le
critiquer ou alors à gauche et bien jean
luc mélenchon exactement pour cette même
raison le député elle est fille françois
ruffin a quant à lui appelé à manifester
il ya eu plusieurs appels dans toute la
france et le 14 juillet il avait eu
selon les autorités selon le ministère
de l'intérieur
dix neuf mille personnes qui avaient
manifesté dans toute la france merci à
lucas pourquoi toutes ces précisions et